it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get to rev up with
trials fusion jumping onto platforms
everywhere it's so extreme the fifth
game in the trial series is the first
one to be released on a Playstation
platform they can join in on all the
free styling fun and remind everyone
that they have a bike and it's super
cool rag doll your way to victory April
16 also this week you get to join a
large-scale conflict where the Western
forces clash against the communist bloc
command the military resources of 17
nations to take control of command tanks
planes helicopters new Warships and in
fib eous units to dominate the
battlefield the exciting RTS with
non-stop action proves once again would
everybody already knew war it's
fantastic start chasing the dragon April
17 but what about all the Vita and 3ds
owners there hasn't been a new release
in a while but have no fear conception
to children of the seven stars is a
dungeon crawling baby making RPG from
Atlas that is just as creepy as that
sounds in the game you class mate with
seven heroines to produce offspring with
varying abilities that's right classmate
now that's what I call it StreetPass
start making babies April fifteenth
these no no oddities
from Jan Jensen creator of the
best-selling Gabriel Knight series comes
the kick started third person point and
click paranormal mystery Mobius Empire
rising you play Malachi a keen-eyed
historian that takes a good look at
antiques to make sure they're real
putting them in some tricky situations
start antiquing April fifteenth and
finally the football game with a name
that just rolls off the tongue 2014 fifa
world cup brazil it's like a party and
only last gen consoles are invited but
if you're a sports fan with a current
gen console ea didn't forget about you
there's always NBA live 14 cheer up
sport for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week
you